welcome to this video playing demise CC
okay that new account pretty seems fresh
okay and let's see answer some more
you're the territory for me after losing
the last game with white and some
offbeat French line the marker gone off
variation now you can go G 4 I really
have to learn this a little bit better
at one point being more comfortable with
them and different move orders black can
employ a number of move orders and they
are all somewhat different okay maybe
just this it's easy to to confuse them
various some move orders that black and
go for it wasn't strictly necessary but
I wanted to have bishop well he can go
Bishop f6 now Wow but should be three
Bishop H Form 93 wasn't mindless move
really why did I do that that wasn't
good it was far far too quickly played
but should we have six now is good for
black
I have no good move after that yeah of
course and it's very simple this is
there the bad thing man ah there should
be three Bishop F Bishop hym it looks
pretty awful to go to you too Bert and
that trading the bishop is also bad i
have three was really a double ? move
awful absolutely awful
check I don't want to trade the dark
squared bishop I mean this looks this
looks like looks looks looks like red
but whatever f3 is what a howl of
completely idiotic meals you can slip
like Queenie 78 Bishop g5 the only good
thing about this is that is actually
taking some time him which is not really
necessary Black has easy moves let's say
I Kim yeah I can win that porn is simply
a win that now I don't care this game
looks like I'm a complete idiot anyway
so I got to continue in that fashion he
tried to snatch up on him come on give
me that born it's not it's not even
entirely clear how bad this is T can go
Queenie 14 Queen edge for it that
actually seems playable yeah wants to go
to g3 it's not not a big problem I guess
92 will force some trade
yeah as amazing as it sounds this is
actually quite okay for white I guess
unless my queen gets trapped which might
happen but now III check king be one huh
what is this I don't quite understand it
hmm it's not going to play 93 anytime
soon okay we should any division 1 d3
getting things developed just route g5
and rukia one next whoa look g5 queen
deform i can sacrifice on h5 takes takes
takes check
I don't don't don't see how this group
chief I've come on Group chief 524 I
mean even if it checks me that I don't
see I mean if I take on age five I can't
I think I cannot go to g1 I should be
aware of that ok I'm just going no
nighty too romantic d3
I just need to be a little bit precise
here then then it's it's probably going
to be a win what about if I am 24 root g
5 24 if I just play but should be two
then the I just I can't defend that
don't believe it for just for Luke g1
just keeping this and I go rook g1 next
don't see how a defense against that
he's got no check a bishop a for but ok
and it doesn't do anything
and now for ticket it doesn't like
antique Queenie 7mm now that still seems
to somehow defend it looks bad but still
seems to defend somehow probably this
494 and let's do this
yeah but now this Knight f6 also time
one each at this is this is no tough to
believe Knight f6 or 95
no not if sex is good enough no is the g
one is hanging actually the g one is
hanging I with the shadows wins this
wins I think this is probably going to
be made yeah I can go back I really
struggling with us know that it's
quidditch five mate ok and 25 g 7 is
also made check check check mate huh
yeah well that was very strange I mean I
played this like a complete [ __ ] in the
opening f3 is it's just terrible
terrible move yeah I am and not quite
sure what I should do maybe just take it
I mean this this is probably right but
f3 is just amazingly awful yeah now I
mean you absolutely don't want to trade
those bishops when you have all your
pawns on light squares and your king is
only one um yeah maybe yeah I don't know
yeah that looks really bad yeah but I
mean maybe you cannot open up the
deposition so quickly that's that's
possible yeah I don't believe in that so
much I feel like I'm really better now
because it is a closed center and you
know yeah why the sclera better the
engine confirms that it wasn't a great
idea if I'm sure to give up give up that
porn maybe it should be too now is
better but very likely there is some
quicker way to win nobody should be too
is actually the engine move so I can be
happy with that group g1 here i knowi
five does win so I didn't play that so
terribly if I've does win even though
the engine wants to take now on age five
and play this which wins the Queen
admittedly I'm does those made threats
can also only answered by the Queen sec
but that should win as well right yeah
it does that's good chat is this check
this actually loses whoa whoa why is it
losing this wins let's let's check first
why that wins Bishop f7 Queen g5 this is
made it seems yeah because Knight f6 and
there's okay let's err that I understand
so here and then Queen g5 huh again I'm
winning I'm winning the the Queen and
I'm taking this twice this is kind of
important so that this this is actually
a whelming from material point of view
so that move is losing aha due to King
age eight i was thinking i can actually
play nine f7 check here I haven't he can
take a look haha you can take with the
rook and now as this one oh my god whoo
wow that was lucky yeah this is hanging
I don't have time form for some kind of
slow move yeah I was a whole whole big
mess this game very very bad opening and
and the play afterwards now let's not
talk about that whoo thanks for watching